Graphene is heralded as a wonder-material
that could completely change our world.
Its incredibly flexible, strong and conductive
carbon structure promises to revolutionize
energy storage, computing, and technology
as we know it.
But graphene isn’t the only nanocarbon out
there with promising applications.
There’s one in particular that’s been
capturing scientists’ attention for decades,
and it has the potential to be even more game-changing
than our fan favorite graphene.
The only thing is, no one’s actually figured
out how to make it... until now.
Currently, scientists know how to create two
kinds of nanocarbons; those with positive
curvature, like nanotubes and buckyballs,
and those with zero curvature, like graphene.
But scientists have theorized that a third
group should exist-- nanocarbons with negative
curvature, also known as Schwarzites.
We’ve made them before on a much larger
scale out of polymers and have found them
to be remarkably light and strong.
Swap these polymers for sheets of carbon molecules,
and in theory, you have a schwarzite, a 3D
version of graphene.
Its negative curvature creates a structure
with an optimized balance of surface area
and interior volume.
And that’s the clincher, because then you’d
then have the conductivity of graphene arranged
elegantly in 3 dimensions, in a way that can
store an enormous amount of electrical charge.
See, since batteries and supercapacitors require
3-dimensional electrodes to store energy,
scientists have had to force 2d graphene into
3d structures to make it useful in those applications.
But, schwarzites solve that problem altogether
because they’re already 3D.
This could lead to supercapacitors that charge
your phone in seconds and batteries that can
store more energy and that have longer lifetimes.
But... all of this rests on scientists being
able to actually make carbon schwarzites.
Aaand… that’s proven difficult.
But we haven’t given up, and after decades
of searching, new international research led
by a team at UC Berkeley has finally cracked
the code.
To make their schwarzites, the team used materials
called zeolites, which are porous minerals
commonly used in laundry detergent.
The researchers injected a vapor of carbon
molecules into the pores of these zeolite
structures, and watched as the carbon arranged
itself in sheets along the insides of the
pores.
Then, all they had to do was dissolve the
zeolite away and voila!
A bonafide schwarzite.
So boom we did it!
Time to go make supercapacitors and batteries
out of this ish, right?
Well, not exactly.
This newest research was done on a computer,
as a simulation.
And while it proves this process could work,
scientists will still need to experiment to
find the best conditions to actually make
it in the lab.
Then, once they do that, they still need to
find a method that’s cost effective before
we see it in any commercial applications.
But don’t get too depressed, as the author
of the paper pointed out, “that’s the
same story that was given for graphene 10
years ago,” and since then, the cost has
come way down, and graphene is starting to
make its way onto the commercial stage.
So, as for our schwarzite fantasies, maybe
it’s only a matter of time.
One last thing, Schwarzites are named after
19th century German scientist, Hermann Schwarz,
who studied the negative curvature in soap
bubbles, you know, because that’s what I’d
like to spend my days doing.
Subscribe to Seeker to make sure you never
miss a nanocarbon update, and while we’re
waiting for schwarzites to take over the world,
check out Julian’s video here to learn about
a different way to improve supercapacitors
that involves… contact lenses!
I’m Maren, thanks for watching Seeker.